- It's like one of those weird
Oreo flavors that you're like, never!
And, then you taste it and
you're like, maybe always.
(whirring)
(metal squeaking)
(upbeat techno music)
- I love Hot Cheetos, I'm
like one of those people
that just licks the Hot Cheetos
dust off my hands.
(chuckling)
Like, it's like muah!
- Use it as like a foundation,
you're like "mmmm"!
- Yeah, just everything!
- They're like a wonderful
like snack when you're hungry,
when you're just like craving
something to munch on,
when you, when
- When you're high.
(chuckling)
- I've just always loved them even
though they do my body wrong,
and I'm talking about the poops.
- Do you see this?
- Wow!
(gasping excitedly)
(chuckling)
- It's exactly what I thought it was!
- What, this is exactly
what you thought it was?
- When I close my mind
and I think Hot Cheeto Bagel, it's this!
- This is
- It's kind of like a nice
little gradient inside, though.
- This is nuts.
- I have Ghost Pepper for one bite
and then I have Ranch,
Cool Ranch on the other.
- If you love spices, I would eat this,
eat this and dip this in the Ghost Pepper.
- It definitely tastes more authentic.
- More crunch, because what's
a Cheeto without crunch?
- I prefer the bagel with the Cool Ranch
because the Ghost Pepper is hot.
(exclaiming surprise)
- Man!
That's the one you feel in your sinuses.
(pleasantly gasping)
- That's so good!
- Sweating on my forehead,
now from eating it.
- Yeah, Hot Cheeto sweats.
(denim flapping)
- You did it, Hot Cheeto
Bagel, you surprised me.
- You did it.
(chuckling)
- Came through!
- If I saw like a bagel
like this on my Instagram ?,
I would double-tap it because
it does look pretty cute.
- And, I'm glad I could check this off
of my Hot Cheeto bucket list.
- Brilliant!
Do you think you'd
wanna have sex with that Cheeta man?
- I think probably, also
why does he never take off
his sunglasses; I don't trust
people that wear
- It's because he
doesn't have eyes,
it's just smooth under there.
- Oh, God!
(laughing)